I forgot we're doing his this game ever
taking the same guy and Averett hi we're
jb antony and we're here at BuzzFeed
taking a BFF test their birthday your
birthday is March 14 huh can I get two
options for yours mm-hmm your birthday
is right after mine and it's the 20th no
24th no 27
no it's March yeah yeah yeah and then
that makes you a series cuz I'm an Aries
but are you on the cusp of a Pisces
thank you for saving my ass I'm a Pisces
and you're an area yeah you know my
middle name is really it that's so
really no it's like a very it's very
it's like a hilarious name yes it is
isn't it kind of Irish eat a little bit
more Scottish a little Irish it's kinda
like a fast food chain McDonald's yeah
what's your middle name is something
polish mm-hmm it's my dad's first name
oh of course it is
yeah he and Anusha yeah yeah
sounds like a bread piece but I want to
eat your hometown is Quincy Illinois
yeah and your hometown is Montreal yes
it is yeah cuz you're the first American
Canadian that wasn't born in Europe in
your family exactly yeah your favorite
musician is of course the the the stroke
I'm not sure why you had to say with
that kind of it well cuz you loved those
t-shirts I wore them in like the first
two seasons your favorite we've done
five or six seasons of the show and I
have not one night since I'm a lot more
than just a strokes even though I love
the strokes yeah anybody who's a female
singer you love your Liz so you love
Beyonce you love Christina when the time
is right dirty love I love Ariana even
Britney not as much I don't hear as many
references I love that one song perfume
I love her feels really good song I love
a lot yours is that really really sad
one that makes you cry a lot that you
always gonna take a picture of them it's
like it's like is that really fat the
way you generalize about things it's
called a little life by honey oh yeah
everyone should know about it but that I
get photo guy you're acting like I carry
it around with me everywhere and
everyone takes a photo no one photo was
thank you wonderful I do a lot more than
just a little like you know it's a 40
important what's your favorite book um I
love like I loved everything that might
Angela never wrote and I also loved
Bridget Jones and Harry Potter yeah like
that for you
favorite movie Sister Act for you 1 & 2
but choose probably more so for me yeah
what about yours my favorite no I know
what your favorite movie is you know
you're never gonna get it take [ __ ]
that's a good one but no cinema paradiso
oh your favorite TV shows queer I yes
you're just - yeah yes we have that in
common
favorite British bacon challenge then
you know that and like how we're just
answering our own questions 30 rock oh
you love three I should have known that
Keith oh we both love Katy together it's
our favorite snack food and we had an in
Quincy Illinois and where we went to
your favorite pizza place Howard power
and we took a crust of the pizza which
is usually very underappreciated but
when you dip it into queso makes a lot
of sense and then your mom made us
coffee cake sausage pepperoni onion
pizza from there it's just okay it was
very little bad because they render all
the fat from the sausage and it's
crunchy and the pepperonis crispy and
has those little pools of fat it's not
be any excess my favorite holiday we
both liked Christmas a lot mm-hmm
what do you like more than Christmas
Thanksgiving that makes sense but that
also makes me feel guilty why because
you know we don't even really learn
about what really happened we certainly
don't [ __ ] table so let's take it from
like a very very you know a time when
you get to see your family yeah
your favorite coffee order is a venti
coffee really hot with a little bit of
heavy cream I like oh you like
half-and-half or heavy
they're similar they are yeah well your
coffee order is obviously a nitrile cold
brew with nothing in it or a block cold
brew or an iced - okay or hot espresso
or a hot coffee cuz it's kind of cold
now your favorite season I feel like you
love fall yeah right mm-hmm and that's
mine too I was just talking to someone
recently I know yours what yeah I I was
talking to someone I was telling them
how I had a really big crush on Gwen
Stefani and I thought that that made me
like really strained and they were like
that's actually like pretty gay you like
like all gay guys had a big crush on
Gwen Stefani or Pamela Anderson that was
my go-to when people Vic who do you
think it's hot when I was what I'd be
like Baywatch anyone on Baywatch
I know where yours is where you have
that big one on you're finished you're
right at your budget no I don't you yeah
yeah in its shape just like nice Danny
and kills no that's a tattoo I got a few
a really big one on my ankle you do and
my sister has a time with you and my
sister has exactly if I never knew on
the same spot really there you go how
cute you know their finest I had a full
skin test I'm not feeling great about
that I had a full dermatology skin test
and I even born I'm rivet found one here
and it wasn't it's just because I have
this genetic thing where I get tiny
little red spots as I get older and it's
totally fine
I'm very careful I had everything
checked he like goes to your driver
everywhere go see your dermatologist get
all your Mon chéri Berg yeah oh I know
mine is no that's not the game your
favorite ice cream is feel like you owe
her fear ice cream flavor is big and
marscapone with balsamic no it's really
gorgeous I've had it before and I only
said that because you like really just
in your diapers you know I do like it
but if I'm gonna have to pick two for me
it would be pistachio for assaulting her
about the caramel swirl you would have
never guessed yes I could have yours
would be like a s'more ice cream
your biggest pet peeve is when I'm not
awake in the mornings uh yeah I do hate
that your official winter lights hanging
I think yours maybe would have been like
English yeah yeah yeah yours was um your
band stuff gymnastics what no I probably
liked like um I feel like I liked like
history you would like history that's
dumb I should have guessed that one
my biggest fear um mmm
carbs after nine what's my biggest fear
I actually have two so you better like
not make a joke because mine was really
funny
I don't know spiders and snakes I'm on
board with that because spiders look
like aliens and snakes don't have a
limbs it is unnatural
thanks BuzzFeed they know each other so
well oh well thank you so much tune into
Netflix queer I were in Japan streaming
now streaming no streaming it's gorgeous
uh goodbye I've never waved like that
ever in my life but why would I do in
there
[Music]